you probably already know that the main
function of the heart is to pump blood
through our circulatory system so the
blood comes in it gets pumped it comes
in deoxygenated that's why it's colored
blue here then it gets pumped out to the
lungs they get it gets oxygenated in the
lungs then it comes back into the heart
to get pumped out to the rest of the
body so to make sure that the oxygen is
distributed now whenever someone talks
about heart disease and eventually heart
attacks a lot of times people talk about
clogged arteries and when I first heard
that when I was a kid I assumed that hey
the heart is this pump and it has these
arteries that are supplying blood to the
rest of the body that's what that must
be what people are talking about when
they talk about clogged arteries may be
some type of clogging forms and these
really big arteries over here and at
some point they get so big that the
blood can't flow through them and then
the person the person dies and that's
what I used to think what a heart attack
was when when I was a kid
but this is not the case this is not the
case when people talk about coronary
artery disease or when they talk about
clogged arteries they're not talking
about the these big arteries or the big
veins that are going to or away from the
heart they're actually talking about the
smaller arteries that are actually
supplying blood to the heart so when
people talk about coronary artery
disease when they talk about clogged
arteries not these big pipes they're
talking about the supply of blood to to
the heart so the first thing when people
talk about kind of clogged arteries the
official thing they're referring to is
atherosclerosis fancy word but all it
really means is let me show you
atherosclerosis and I'm not going to go
into the details of how of how these
arterial walls actually thicken I could
probably do a couple of videos on that
but the general idea if this is if this
is an artery over here over time you
have these plaques develop you have
these plaques develop inside of the
arterial inside of the arterial wall and
they thin they restrict the amount of
blood that can flow through the artery
and these plaques these are kind of
combinations these plaques right here
are combinations of
lipids so lipids are things like
cholesterol and fats and you also have a
bunch of white blood cells in here so
you also have white blood cells many of
them might be dead white blood cells so
over time these plaques can kind of
build up in the arteries start to
restrict the flow of blood through the
artery and if these get these get thick
enough and they restrict the flow of
blood this is what we call coronary
artery disease let me write that down
coronary coronary artery artery disease
and the main symptom that someone would
experience if they have coronary artery
disease so I want to I want to make it
very clear what I'm talking about I'm
not talking about these big pipes I'm
not talking about these big pipes that
go into or away from the heart I'm
talking about the arteries that supply
blood to the actual muscles of the heart
remember the heart is made up of muscles
it needs blood itself to do the pumping
it needs oxygen itself so what you can
imagine happens in one of these arteries
that supply blood to the heart right
over here and just so you know some of
these names you might hear them throwing
around this this on the left-hand side
on the red let me label it over here
this in red over here this is the left
coronary artery sometimes called the LCA
you might say wait this is the one on
the right but we're thinking about it
from the point of view of the person
whose heart it is so that's why it's
their left coronary artery this right
here is the right coronary artery and
these are the ones or some branches off
of them that might get that might that
might have thickening of the walls so
what you imagine this plaque could form
maybe it's forming right over here let
me do that in a different color
maybe it's forming right over here and
so when you have this platform right
over here where it's going to do is it's
going to reduce it's going to reduce
blood flow to all of these parts let me
draw that a little bit neater it will
reduce blood flow to all of this kind of
downstream part of the artery and
because it's reducing blood flow all of
the muscle around here all of the
muscles that gets its oxygen that's fed
oxygen from kind of the downstream part
of the artery they
get enough oxygen and they won't be able
to pump properly and so the main symptom
of coronary artery disease is called
angina pectoris
you might have so angina and Jona
pectoris and it's usually just called
angina for short
but angina pectoris literally means a
strangling like feeling in the chest and
you get that strangling like feeling in
the chest because your heart is not
getting enough oxygen to pump properly
but at this point you still don't have a
heart attack a heart attack happens
where one of these plaques are unstable
enough so they might have a little
membrane covering the top of it but
they're unstable enough so that they
eventually because of the because of the
blood flow then the pressure from the
blood they eventually break off so they
eventually break off and go into the
blood so then you have all of the
material enters in the blood and then
the blood actually clots around it and
so the blood actually clots around it so
here the blood is clotting around all of
these materials so you had if plaque now
it was unstable and so at some point it
just randomly breaks off all of all of
this blood clots around this and then
it's going downstream it's going
downstream where the arteries get
thinner and thinner and thinner so you
can imagine if this thing right here was
unstable it could get dislodged over
there let me do this in a color we can
see it gets dislodged over there you
still can't see that color it gets
dislodged over there and if it goes
downstream the arteries get narrow
narrow and at some point it could get it
could it could it'll get stuck in a
thinner part of the artery so a good
downstream until it gets stuck and at
that point is completely blocking that
artery and this completely blocking of
the artery from a kind of a blood clot
that came off of one of these unstable
plaques this is called thrombosis so
this right here is thrombosis thrombosis
so it's the blocking of an artery due to
a plaque but once you block that artery
then not none of the none of the none of
the muscles that that artery was feeding
can now get oxygen
everything downstream from that will no
longer be able to get oxygen and so what
you'll see is that this muscle over here
that needs that oxygen it will start to
die it will start to it will start to
infarct and I know this is a very
strange word infarct is literally it
dead is literally dead tissue so what
you have over here some of this muscle
tissue on the heart that's not getting
proper blood anymore it experiences
infarction or the or the proper term for
it is myocardial infarction myocardial
myocardial infarction and this is a very
fancy word but really it's just saying
myocardial is actually the muscle tissue
of the heart infarction mean it's dying
so part of the heart the muscle tissue
of the heart is dying over here and so
when you have mato when you have
myocardial infarction all of a sudden
because this happens this isn't
something that happens slowly remember
this the plaque might form slowly over
over years over decades but eventually
becomes unstable and then one day just
breaks apart and this whole time you
might have been experiencing something
called stable angina stable angina means
hey you got this thing over here
you're usually okay but if you start
jogging maybe you start getting a little
bit of chest pain that's stable angina
but it's kind of predictable if you
start exerting yourself you get chest
pain now all of a sudden you're going to
experience something called unstable
angina that just because this just
happened you're going to experience this
kind of probably stronger pain it's
going to be all of a sudden and that's
probably because you have muscle tissue
that just now started to die so all of a
sudden your your your heart's ability to
pump got a lot worse than it was before
and this this myocardial infarction this
this this dying of muscle tissue this is
a heart attack this is what people talk
about when they say when they say
someone is having a heart attack now I
want to differentiate between the word
heart attack and another word that
sometimes used synonymously with it and
that's cardiac arrest cardiac cardiac
arrest and they're used to non ously
because sometimes they happen at the
same time if enough if the heart attack
is big enough if enough of the heart
dies
it might stop the heart from being able
to pump all together it might actually
make the heart stopped and that stopping
of the heart is cardiac arrest but there
are two different things
the heart attack or the myocardial
infarction is a dying of some of the
muscles so someone can have a heart
attack
and get through and actually survive a
heart attack it's just that their heart
will be impaired after that their heart
won't be as strong as it was before
every heart attack every myocardial
infarction does not lead to cardiac
arrest cardiac arrest means the heart is
has stopped that the person unless they
can be revived in some way if the if the
if the heart stays arrested that person
that person will will pass away a heart
attack they're not necessarily going to
pass away now another term that tends to
be confused with heart attack and
cardiac arrest is the is the word heart
failure which sounds just as bad as
cardiac arrest heart failure because
cardiac arrest is the heart actually
stopping but heart failure is actually
not quite as bad it's not something
you'd want to experience but heart
failure is actually just the notion that
the heart is not able to pump enough
blood for the body's needs so the heart
failure out of out of these three things
it's probably the most benign it's still
something you don't want to have and
it's probably in it's probably an
indication that you're that some of
these other things might be coming soon
but cardiac arrest is a stopping of the
heart myocardial infarction or a heart
attack is some part of the heart dying
because it's not able to get oxygen
because some artery has been blocked
because of an unstable plaque and heart
failure is just the general term that
you're living the heart hasn't stopped
but it's not able to fully give all of
the oxygen that the body needs so it'll
really affect someone's lifestyle so
hopefully that clarifies a lot of things
about the heart and what a heart attack
and what heart disease is